Great.
So we'll get started.
Um,
any Duke has devoted her life to the study of decision making under pressure
during your careers.
Professional Poker player.
She won over $4 million in tournaments around the world series of poker bracelet
as the only woman to have won the world series of Poker Tournament of champions
and the BC national heads up poker championship,
retired from poker since 2012.
She is now a corporate speaker and a consultant on decision strategy merging her
poker expertise and her graduate level research in psychology at the University
of Pennsylvania.
She has authored five books,
is a cofounder of how I decide.
Dot Org.
Serves on the board of afterschool all stars and is a trustee of the Franklin
Institute.
She's also wanted,
uh,
televised championship in rock,
paper,
scissors.
Is that a high stake game of rock,
paper,
scissors?
Yeah,
I think I won like $10,000.
I'd say high stakes.
Yeah,
Mama for and she lives outside Philadelphia.
So let's welcome her to Google.
Um,
so,
and you want to start with,
um,
what inspired you to write this book?
Oh Wow.
That's a very broad question.
So I,
you know,
I used to joke,
the joke that I used to make was I,
for most of my professional career,
I spent my life taking advantage of people who made decisions that weren't so
good.
So maybe I should spend some of my life trying to help people make better
decisions.
Um,
so that's kind of the cheeky answer,
but I think that what actually really inspired me to write the book was that I
started off my life in academics.
I was,
I was at the University of Pennsylvania.
I was studying cognitive science,
which is really of course a study of the way that our brains interact with the
environment.
How do we process information as it comes in?
Um,
I was getting my phd in that,
you know,
had a national science foundation fellowship and I was on my way to become a
professor.
Um,
and right at the end of that journey,
I actually got sick.
I ended up with a stomach problem that landed me in the hospital for a couple of
weeks and I ended up missing the job market for that year because it's seasonal.
So I had to take time off just to recuperate and I was going to go back out on
the market the next year.
And I,
I ended up in that year.
That's when I took this,
what felt like this very big left turn into poker.
Um,
so I started playing poker and uh,
about eight years into it,
um,
I got asked by a actually a retreat of options traders if I could come speak to
them about the way that poker might inform their decision making and how they
handle risk.
Um,
and it was this moment where I realized,
you know,
Oh gosh,
I thought I took this really huge left turn out of academics,
but I didn't,
I landed in just a really amazing natural laboratory to study.
How do we make decisions under conditions of uncertainty when the outcomes of
those decisions are not very well connected to the quality of the decision
making itself.
It's just a very noisy environment.
And how are you pulling the signal out and how are you learning under those
circumstances?
And the answer is not so well really.
Um,
and it was this moment of kind of revelation for me as I was,
as I was thinking like,
what am I going to say to this group of people?
Because I,
it was this kind of moment where it all came together for me where I said,
you know,
it's really interesting because I was taught in graduate school that learning
occurs under conditions where you have lots and lots of feedback tied closely in
time to decisions and actions.
And as I'm going to go talk to these people,
what I realize is poker is the ultimate.
Lots and lots of feedback tied closely in time.
I mean like within 30 seconds of time to decisions and actions.
And yet what I saw was that learning was not occurring very well.
And so it was that moment of wanting to square those two things together.
And after that first talk,
I just went along,
you know,
I was like,
oh.
And I started building this second career and,
and speaking to audiences about how poker is a kind of a really great platform
and framework for kind of understanding not only what are the problems in
decision making,
but how can we kind of solve for them.
Um,
and I sort of feel like from 2002 I was just workshopping this material and that
I was finding this incredible joy and sharing these ideas,
um,
with people in a way that was felt really different to me than poker.
In poker.
I'm thinking about these ideas in a way that's very zero sum,
right?
I'm going to win.
You're going to lose,
you're going to win.
I'm going to lose.
Um,
and you know,
when I started doing this in 2002,
I started growing that business and it started to become a much bigger part of
my life actually than the poker was in it.
It just felt in this really nice way,
like I was adding water sort of back into the ocean.
Um,
and you know,
that's,
this book sort of,
you know,
came out of that whole journey that I took.
So can we talk about what prevents people from making good decisions?
Oh,
that's cause that's that.
Do we want to narrow that down?
What prevents people from making good decisions?
I think it's a collision of a couple of problems.
I think that,
um,
the,
the first pieces is uncertainty and uncertainty comes from two places.
Uh,
it comes from hidden information.
So this is where we can see how poker might be a really good way to look at
decision making.
The first place it comes from is hidden information.
So in poker,
the cards are face down.
Guess what?
In life as well,
there's very often a lot of information asymmetry,
right?
Um,
and,
and there's lots of stuff that we can't know and there's lots of things that we
don't know.
So that's the first place that uncertainty comes from.
But even if we did have perfect information,
say for example,
about a coin,
and we know that heads or tails,
it's gonna flip 50% of the time.
We also have the intervention of luck,
which is the other form of uncertainty.
Um,
so even if I know everything I need to know about the coin,
so there's no hidden information about the coin,
that doesn't mean I can predict whether it will flip heads or tails on the next
try.
I can say something over 10,000 tries.
I can tell you how it's gonna work out over time.
But most of what we're doing is actually sort of these one trial,
um,
scenarios,
and particularly as we're trying to make decisions and learn from the outcomes
of our decisions were not very good.
Aggravators so we're not sitting back,
well,
first of all,
most of the decisions we make,
we couldn't get 10,000 trials even.
So,
um,
but even if we could,
the data's kind of coming in one at a time as we're out sort of in the field
making her own decisions.
And so we're at,
we're sort of encoding everything one at a time.
We're not sitting back and saying,
let me not making any decisions,
um,
until I have lots and lots of data.
And in fact,
that would be impractical because like for example,
you would never say get married to somebody.
Then,
right,
because you'd have to get so many trials in order to know that you were sure.
So it's that it's not practical to do anyways.
So the first piece,
the first problem is that there's all this uncertainty.
And then the second problem is that nature,
the way that our brains are built has given us a lot of rope to hang ourselves
with the uncertainty.
Um,
and we can sort of go back to sort of the beginning,
which is what are the types of errors that evolution built us to make?
Because there are a type one errors and type two errors,
a type one.
Errors are false positives and type two errors are false negatives.
Um,
and we're really,
really built for hotspot,
false positives.
We connect things together.
We think they're causal.
We think they go together much more often than they,
than they actually do.
Um,
so we're big at patterns.
We love things to be connected together.
Um,
so,
and that causes a problem.
So that's sort of problem number one.
And we can think about that in the sense of which is worth,
if you're on the Savannah and you hear wrestling,
you know,
among the reeds,
are you,
is it,
are you going to wait and say,
oh,
let me try to figure out if there's actually a lion here or are you going to run
away?
Right?
So obviously we're going to run away.
Um,
so that's number one.
Number two is we're built for tribes.
So there was a lot of advantage for us surviving if we came together in groups
and we had tribes.
And so that causes a problem as well for decision making because it causes these
problems and the way that we process information from things that are outside of
our tribe.
So that's kind of the number two problem.
Um,
and then the number three problem is,
is really,
I,
I talk about this a lot in the book is that we aren't really built to disconfirm
the things that we already believe.
Um,
we're very much built to affirm our priors.
and so when you think about the uncertainty and the way that we sort of
interpret information as it comes in,
there's so much uncertainty in,
in the data that we're getting,
that it gives us the room to just process the world in a way to make us feel
right,
um,
about the things that we already believe.
And when you have that collision between that,
the false positive problem and then the tribal problem on top of that,
like things really fall apart.
Now your book,
you were talking about this beliefs people have about showing the right
information to people and somehow it will get them to see things correctly.
Can you talk more about that too?
Sorry.
I,
so I think that this is part of the problem is that,
um,
we have these ways that we process information.
Um,
so,
uh,
an example that I talk about it and my book is something called motivated
reasoning.
So I think you've all probably heard about confirmation bias.
So motivated reasoning is a larger problem than confirmation bias.
So in confirmation bias,
we have some sort of prior belief,
um,
and we'll notice stuff that confirms the belief and we just kind of won't notice
things that disconfirm the belief motivated reasoning is let's think about this
as an umbrella problem of which confirmation bias as part,
which is that we actually are motivated to confirm the beliefs we have and that
drives our information processing.
So that means that not only will we,
um,
process him from,
well,
we sort of noticed stuff that confirms us and not notice things that disconfirm
us,
but also when confronted with information that disconfirms us,
we work very,
very hard to discredit it.
And when confronted with information that confirms us,
we actually don't put any effort into the [inaudible] at all.
So we don't really vet it very hard.
So I,
and you guys can probably feel that way,
right?
When I read a article that say politically agrees with me,
I'm like,
wow,
that's a really smart article.
Um,
and when it disagrees with me political,
I am like that,
you know,
they're looking at this study and the n is too small and the,
they weren't looking at this data and they were asking the wrong questions and
the person isn't reliable anyway and they forgot all this other stuff and
they're totally biased.
Um,
and you know,
it's weird cause I just don't go through that process with the things that agree
with me.
Strange.
Um,
okay.
So,
so not only that,
then we have this other issue,
which is that when we're in a tribe,
part of the part of what a tribe gives you is,
um,
kind of fourth.
It gives you a sense of belongingness,
a sense of distinctiveness,
right?
So you belong to a tribe,
you're distinct from other tribes in some way where you process that as being
superior.
It,
um,
gives you,
uh,
the idea of sort of what's moral and what's not is also including the tribe.
But then it also gives you something really important for this talk today,
which is called epistemic closure.
Meaning that the tribe is telling you what knowledge is true and trustworthy and
what is not.
So I think that a lot of times what we sort of think,
and this is where we understand this,
the motivated reasoning with the collision of the tribal problem,
well we sort of think is,
oh,
if other people just had the information,
we'd all be fine.
Cause then we'd all sort of believe the same things,
right?
So if we were all working with the exact same information,
we'd all be good.
But that's assuming that we live in something that we're all living in epistemic
bubbles versus echo chambers.
So let me just explain what the differences.
Um,
an epistemic bubble is.
You have,
you have information and you don't have other information period.
So if you're in an epistemic bubble where you just haven't been,
you just haven't gotten the information,
then if you get exposed to the information,
you incorporate it and you're all good.
But epistemic bubbles are pretty rare.
What we mostly live in this echo chamber.
So echo chambers are,
it doesn't matter whether we have the information or not people outside the
group or not trusted sources.
So if you get information that disagrees with you,
that's coming from someone outside the group,
it's not trusted anyway.
And you can see how you can use that in order to accomplish the goals of
motivated reasoning.
So when you're now confronted with information that disagrees with you,
um,
the way that you actually,
one of the ways you discredit it is to talk about the trustworthiness of the
source.
So,
you know,
what we want to be really careful about is,
um,
we want to try to apply as we're trying to imagine,
and I talk about this in the book,
is we're trying to sort of vet information that comes in.
We want to apply a particular norm called universalism,
which is separating the person who's delivering the news from whether the news
itself is correct or not.
So the way I put it in the book is it doesn't really matter whether it's,
um,
you know,
Copernicus or Mussolini or your mom who tells you that the earth is round.
The,
the fact of the roundness of the earth is independent of those sources.
So I,
you know,
in order to actually be good universalists it's usually pretty good as you're
sort of having these reactions to information to try to imagine it absence of
the source or to try to imagine it being delivered from a source that you
actually trust.
And,
and that actually helps you to vet the information independently of the source,
which we're really,
really,
really bad at.
And it's part of this problem of echo chambers.
So,
um,
you were talking about systems of how we can overcome that and looking at
decisions in terms of bets.
Can you talk?
Sure.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
the premise of the book is called thinking in bets and,
and the premise is that if we were more explicit in imagining,
uh,
or in,
in actually just making clear that every decision that we make as a bet,
um,
that we would actually better or be better off and it would create a lot more
open mindedness.
Um,
and why is it,
well,
first of all,
let me try to convince you guys that every decision is a bet.
So that's the first step.
So I actually,
I'll tell a story that I tell in here,
um,
which is kind of a fun story I think.
So there was a guy named,
uh,
John Hennigan,
really,
really great poker player,
known to have a lot of gamble.
And in the 90s when he was in his twenties,
he was really,
if you were to think about sort of what is a,
if you imagine the stereotype of a poker player in,
in 1995,
like John Hennigan would be the guy like he was,
you know,
he never saw the sun.
He was only playing at night.
He was like a total accident junkie.
Like when,
when he was finished at the poker table,
he doesn't want it to gamble more.
Like he was really,
um,
he was very good,
but he really liked a lot of action.
So he was sitting at a poker table one day and,
um,
uh,
discussion broke out out about state capitals and people were like quizzing each
other on state capitals.
So demoine Moines comes up,
um,
and John Hennigan actually announces at the table is they're discussing demoine
oh,
I could totally live in Des Moines.
And,
you know,
De Moines,
obviously reputation is kind of sleepy.
Maybe if you were to think about sort of,
what's the antithesis of Las Vegas,
maybe you would think of de Moines as an example.
Um,
so the,
the players at the table were like,
oh,
come on.
Like there's no way you could live in de Moines.
Um,
but Hennigan actually at that time in his life,
we sort of thinking like,
ah,
you know,
I never see the sun.
And so maybe it will be really nice to go and sort of like detox from Vegas a
little bit.
Um,
and then he also had another thing in mind,
which is that poker players gamble on golf a lot and he thought,
well,
then I could actually really spend some time on golf,
uh,
without the distraction of the actual poker.
So they negotiate a bat.
So at the table they negotiate a bet that,
um,
John Hennigan's going to move to Las Vegas for 30 days.
I mean to des Moines rather for 30 days.
Um,
they add a little bit of a diabolical condition,
which is the hotel that is on is only one street and there's only one restaurant
on the street and there's like no bars,
there's no nightlife,
there's nothing he can,
he's confined to the one street when he moves there for the 30 days,
except there's a specific golf course,
he's allowed to go to the practice golf during the day.
Um,
so they settle on 30 days and the bet is set for $30,000.
So if he can stay in Las Vegas for 30 days,
he wins $30,000.
If he can't stay there and he,
and he has to come back from des Moines,
um,
then he's going to lose $30,000.
So literally the next day he moves to des Moines.
So I,
two days later he calls up the group and he says,
Hey,
I'm in demoine.
I've obviously like I've completely up and move to des Moines.
Clearly I'm good to go.
I'm going to stay here.
So if you'd like to settle,
um,
you guys can pay me $15,000 and I'll come home and I'll save you the misery of
losing the whole 30.
Yeah.
That was the group's reaction.
So they were like,
no,
we're good.
John.
Why don't you,
why don't you stay there?
So a week later,
John Hennigan had moved back from des Moines.
He was,
he was living in Las Vegas and he had paid the group $15,000 for the privilege.
So,
um,
so I tell this story because it sounds like,
oh my gosh,
these crazy poker players making this bet on where John was gonna move.
But if you think about it,
it's really no different than any decision that you've ever made.
I mean,
your decision to come and work at Google,
right?
You have other opportunities.
You're thinking about what John has to think about.
Am I gonna like Des Moines?
He doesn't know because he hasn't lived there before.
Right?
The money that I'm going to make,
if I win this bet,
is it going to be better than the money that I'm going to make if I stay in Las
Vegas and if I'm actually taking less money?
Is that okay because I'm creating different types of opportunities for myself,
like I'm going to feel like I live a healthier life for that month and that
that's worth making less money or I'm going to work on my golf game and that's
going to have payoffs.
Which would be sort of the same as I'm thinking about taking a job in des Moines
and I have to think about how is the morning going to compare to the place that
I live now?
I don't know.
I've never lived there.
Am I going to like it versus any other place that I might possibly move?
Is the salary good enough for me to feel like I'm willing to take that risk in
terms of going and moving there?
What are the opportunities for advancement?
What other kinds of money that you know,
could I make in the future?
Um,
and when you choose to move to des Moines or relocate or take the job at Google,
you're obviously foregoing all other possibilities available to you can only
make the one decision,
which was true for John Hennigan as well.
Um,
so basically Hennigan had a certain set of belief about whether or not he would
like to Moines whether or not it would be worth it to him.
And when he made the choice,
he was foregoing all of their choices,
including staying in Las Vegas and staying with the status quo.
We're moving any other place where he might maybe detox or,
or go,
you know,
detox from the nightlife for go and,
um,
you know,
uh,
practices golf or whatever it might be.
And there was a whole set of possible futures that could occur from that.
One where he stayed in Des Moines for 30 days and left it one where he loved
annoying so much.
He never moved back.
One where he met the love of his life in Des Moines.
You know,
one where he calls up after two days and says,
Hey,
I want to settle.
And the thing is that you don't know,
you're making,
you're making an estimation of what the probability of each of those futures
might be.
And you're deciding that whatever you have to invest in,
it doesn't have to be money.
It can be your health,
your happiness,
your time,
whatever it might be.
Usually it's all of the above.
Whatever you're investing in,
the decision that you,
you actually go with that,
that's gonna hurdle you to the best set of possible futures is compared to any
other decision that you might make.
So the poker players really just make that explicit.
And that's really what you're doing when,
when you're betting is you're making it explicit that a decision is a bet
informed by your beliefs on a set of possible futures that you might be hurdling
yourself too.
So once we kind of understand that frame,
I think that it actually can help us overcome some of these problems that we
have with decision making.
And I'll,
I'll show you a really simple example.
So here's something that's been in the news a lot lately because I hear it every
single day on the news,
the Democrats are going to take the house in the fall.
So,
okay,
so let's say that you said to me,
I,
the Democrats are going to win the house in the fall.
And let's say that my response was,
do you want to bet on that?
So think for yourselves,
what does that do to you?
It causes you to retreat from a place of certainty into a place of probabilistic
thinking,
right?
Because now what you start to think is,
okay,
well wait,
why do I think that?
Oh,
there's a lot of time between now and November.
There's a lot of things that could happen,
right?
Like Trump could solve North Korea.
I don't know.
That might change things,
right?
We don't know.
Um,
you know,
there's all sorts of other things that might happen with Trump.
Trump is somewhat unpredictable.
Um,
there are things that could happen with the Democrats.
There's,
you know,
I mean the number of things that can intervene on the luck side between now and
six months from now is pretty large.
Right?
And so,
so you'll start to think about that it brings is bubbles that uncertainty up to
the four and then you also start to think like,
what,
well,
have I been reading opinions that disagree with that?
Like what,
what is the person who's challenging me to the bet know or think that I haven't
thought of or that I don't know?
I have to start thinking about why might I be wrong here before I'm willing to
actually put that kind of skin into the game.
Right?
And so essentially what this element of,
let me think about my decisions explicitly is as bets does,
is it forces you into more probabilistic thinking into more the recognize the
recognizing of these two forms of uncertainty that I don't ever have perfect
information for pretty much anything,
right?
We just don't and that the future is always uncertain that no matter how well I
think about the future,
how much I predict the future,
even if the only bad outcome can occur 1% of the time it can still happen.
So I need to think about that as a sort of announcing these things with
certainty.
Once you start to bubble up the uncertainty in any decision that you make a
causes you to be much more open minded because now what happens is that you're
thinking about,
well,
if I can only think about if my beliefs are probabilistic and my predictions
about the future of probabilistic than I need to be information hungry because
what I need to do is start refining my beliefs and refining my predictions
because I actually have to bet on these things.
But things like my time and things like my money and things like my health and,
and these limited resources that I have.
And if I can only make one decision at a time,
I better.
And I'm thinking about this probabilistically,
I better start really working to try to refine all of this stuff.
And how am I going to do that?
Well,
it's going to cause me to be open minded in particular to why I'm wrong.
Openminded to opinions and beliefs that disagree with me because I already know
why I'm right.
That's how I got to a place of certainty in the first place.
So once I start backing off of that,
I've got to start thinking about,
you know,
again,
what does the other person know that I don't know.
Um,
and I think that that's why it's such a good frame for trying to solve for some
of these problems.
So you make the bed and it doesn't work out for you.
Like what should your next steps be on hell?
They analyze what happened.
So you make the vet and it doesn't work out for you.
Right.
And so what should your next steps be?
So that's a very good question.
Um,
so it's actually,
it's actually,
uh,
one of the big problems is that once you have a result,
it really distorts your ability to go back in and analyze the decision process.
It's a problem called resulting.
So another story from the book that I'll give to sort of illustrate this problem
and we can talk about solutions for this is,
so do you guys remember,
I'm the 2015 Superbowl sea hawks versus patriots?
Yeah.
So you're in the right area to remember that,
right?
So I mean,
so,
okay,
so it's the last play of the Superbowl.
Uh,
the Seahawks around the one yard line,
26 seconds left.
Uh,
it's second down.
They have one time out in there,
down by four.
So this is obviously a really important decision that's going on here because if
they score,
the Patriots are unlikely to have enough time to be able to march back down the
field and score again.
So,
uh,
if they can get a touchdown here,
this probably even be the game winner.
Um,
which would be a really big deal because the patriots like never lose a
Superbowl until this year.
And I'm from Philly,
but we'll just say,
and I was pretty excited about that.
So,
um,
okay.
So what does Pete Carroll do here?
Um,
he's got a running back on his team named Marshawn Lynch.
Amazing.
Short yardage 20 back.
Everybody's expecting him to hand it off to Marshawn Lynch and instead he calls
past play a Russell Wilson passes the ball and the ball is intercepted pretty
famously and boom,
done.
Malcolm Butler intercepts the ball.
The game is over.
Um,
the in game calling from Chris Collingsworth is,
is pretty brutal,
um,
on this decision.
Uh,
you know,
Pete Carroll Day,
I can't even believe this call,
this such a horrible call.
Um,
and the next day I have to say that most of the pundits did not disagree.
there seem to be an argument among the major outlets,
um,
about whether it was the worst call in Superbowl history,
uh,
which was most of them.
But USA Today actually said it was the worst call and football history period.
So that seems to be where the disagreement way.
Um,
so this is a really good example of resulting,
so we know what the result was.
Horrible,
right?
I mean,
the result was one of the worst results in Superbowl history.
We can agree with on that,
but that does not mean that it was one of the worst decisions in Superbowl
history.
And I think to just declare that that,
uh,
Pete Carol hadn't put any thought into it.
I mean,
this is Pete Carroll.
He's in the Superbowl for a reason.
Um,
you know,
I thought it was pretty spectacular.
So like I'll just ask you guys to do the thought experiment so we can see what
the problem is.
What do you do once you have the result?
Um,
imagine the Pete Carroll passes that ball and the ball is caught for a touchdown
in the end zone.
Just take a moment to think about that.
Now.
How does that decision feel now?
Brilliant.
But how it turns out on that one outcome shouldn't actually affect the way that
we think about the decision,
right?
I mean,
that's like saying,
if I flip a coin and you call heads and it lands heads that that was a brilliant
decision,
but if it lands tails,
that was a really dumb decision.
One outcome tells us nothing.
So,
so I,
but you can feel it.
You can feel that like the,
the result acts like a gravity well and you can't climb out of it to look at
whether the decision process was good or not.
It's really hard now just I just to not leave you with a cliffhanger.
This is,
you know,
the probability of an interception and that spot depends on how many seasons you
aggregate across,
but it's probably somewhere hovering around one or 2%,
right?
So here they declared this like the worst decision ever and like of 1% or hit
basically.
So I don't think that should really say very much about whether the quality of
that decision was any good.
Also,
by the way,
for anybody under who understands the options theory,
remember they only had one time out.
So,
uh,
if a very usual event,
I think it's about 40% of the time that the ball just get isn't complete there.
What happens?
The ball stops and guess what?
They have time for two running place.
So if they hand the ball off to Marshawn Lynch,
they're going to run so much time out that they're only gonna be able to get two
plays off even with being able to call the timeout.
Um,
so they're only going to get to two plays.
If they pass the ball and it's dropped,
they actually get three plays,
including those two running plays that everybody wanted them to run in the first
place.
So it's a somewhat free option.
It costs you about,
you know,
this intersection rate of about 1% for a more detailed analysis.
Benjamin Morris on five 38 has a great one,
highly recommend you go read it.
Um,
but so this is where we can see like once we know the outcome,
once we know whether it's good or bad,
it's incredibly hard for us not to then retrofit the decision quality to the
outcomes.
So the answer is,
unless you've got,
unless you're running a Monte Carlo,
which we can't for most things,
um,
what do we do once an outcome as occurred in terms of how do we move forward?
It's like ignore the outcome as much as possible.
It's actually the weird answer to that.
Um,
and I understand it's counterintuitive,
but it's kind of the only way to move forward is like,
okay,
it was one outcome.
I got to think about the decision in absence of that.
And we can,
if you want,
we can talk about strategies for doing that,
but that'd be great.
Cause you mentioned Phil Ivey
every situation,
look at the skill aspect of it.
What can I control,
what can I improve?
And then you have helped me with who,
I guess his quote is,
I'm would be the best poker player of all time if it wasn't for look.
Yes,
yes.
Talk about that spectrum.
Sure.
Yeah.
So there's only two things that determine the way our lives turn out,
uh,
luck and the quality of our decisions.
So we can't really control the luck element.
So we should try to get down and focus on the quality of the decision.
Um,
so,
uh,
you mentioned Phil Ivey I think is a really good example,
part of the way to do this.
So he,
I tell a story about he wanted a really huge tournament against the really an
all star final table.
Phil Ivy is one of the best poker players in history.
Um,
and he actually went to dinner with my brother and he spent the whole time
talking about all the mistakes that you've made.
So obviously he's got an interest in cognitive style.
Um,
probably one that's partly responsible for,
for how good he is,
but he,
he gives us actually a clue of how to,
how to handle these kinds of situations.
So there's a variety of different,
um,
what we're trying to do is get to a point where we can all be Phil Ivey.
It's very hard to do.
It's very hard to sort of take our great outcomes and look for mistakes.
It's very hard to take our bad outcomes actually and look for it mistakes as
well.
We kind of want to pawn that off on to La.
So what I really talk about in the book is that the way into this is actually to
try to separate outcomes from decision quality as much as possible.
So,
how can we do that?
There's a variety of ways we can do that with tablet sort of strategy number
one,
all of this has done much better in a group by the way.
So,
uh,
and part of that reason is because of this kind of gravity well that we end up
down in,
um,
this is the way our brains work.
It's very hard for us to parse this apart,
but other people can see our bias much better than we can see it in ourselves.
I mean,
you,
you can spot bias thinking a mile away,
right?
So like,
get some people in a group with you who will spot your bias and you'll spot
their bias.
And then here are some things that you can do with that group.
Thing number one is when possible deconstruct decisions before outcomes have
occurred.
So that's really,
really good to do and memorialize it.
So now as you're thinking about the decision,
um,
and what the outcomes might be,
you can write down what you think all the possible outcomes are.
So we can think about this in terms of the Pete Carroll example and there's
like,
okay,
maybe the ball will be caught,
maybe the ball will be draft,
maybe we'll be intercepted.
You try to assign some sort of probability to each of those possible scenarios.
Uh,
you think about what the extra things you're getting out of it or so what are
the payoff in that case,
I'm getting to running plays anyway.
So now what happens is that when the ball gets intercepted,
they're people,
you know,
you're not overreacting to it because you've actually thought about this in
advance and you can actually point and say,
well,
there's the interception scenario.
We thought about that when we thought about the decision and it's happens 1% of
the time.
So let's not overreact to that and like go now change our,
our decision,
the way that we decide in the future to not call that play again because it's
already up there.
So like a trial lawyer can deconstruct their trial strategy before they get,
uh,
you know,
a verdict.
So this,
so that's like one thing you can do when possible,
do as much of the work before you get the outcome.
That's really good.
Uh,
now in poker,
that's actually like literally impossible,
uh,
cause you get the outcome in like 30 seconds.
So,
uh,
there's not a lot of work you can do in that 30 seconds and you can't certainly
can't go off to a group and say,
can we work out the decision tree and then I'll come back to the table and
actually make my decision.
So you can't do that.
So in that case,
what you can do is when you go and you work with whatever your true seeking
group is that you've sort of form to gather the people that you deconstruct
decisions with,
only describe the hand or the question or the decision up to the point that you
need help.
And No,
no further.
So like an example I could give from poker would be,
okay,
I've got a hand.
Uh,
you know,
let's say I had like,
I have King Queen and I opened the pot for a raise and this other guy ray raises
and he's very aggressive and he actually raises a lot.
And so I was trying to decide,
you know,
should I fold or maybe I should reraise him.
What do you think?
So notice I don't,
I know how the hand turned out.
I know how the person responded.
I know I would give a lot more detailed than that leading up to that.
But I know exactly what happened.
But if I'm asking you,
I'm not telling you because our,
our own bias,
these problems are infectious.
So once I tell you the way it turned out,
like let's say that I told you so I decided to reraise and you then moved all in
on me.
You're going to now make a story,
make sense and you're going to now tell me about the decision in a way that's
going to make the fact that that particular result happened.
Makes Sense.
Because that's just the way our minds like to work.
So I'm just going to leave it out and I'm going only get to tell you to the
point that I have a decision.
So that's one thing I can do.
Another thing I can do is to one person I can tell you what worked out well and
to another person I can tell them it worked out poorly so I can change the
stories end.
I think that's a really interesting exercise to do because you will be amazed at
how different the analysis you get,
what the,
what the advice looks like from the person you tell that it ended well versus
the person that you tell it ended poorly.
And I think that then you can sort of look at those two things and kind of work
to merge them together.
Um,
in order to get some fidelity and your ability to actually understand what the
decision quality is.
So that's like another way that you can sort of not infect people.
And you can do this in a variety of ways,
not just with outcomes but with your own beliefs.
So like here's a really simple,
so there's a simple problem which is like if you allow people to talk to each
other,
they sort of try to come to consensus and make beliefs.
Makes Sense.
And you're infecting everybody with your beliefs.
So like here's an example.
Let's say that you have for people who have interviewed somebody that you're
thinking about hiring,
don't let them talk to each other and make them give you their opinions right
down their opinion separately.
Because once they talk to each other,
they've,
there's all this that you've literally infected.
It's like a virus.
Another thing is like,
let's say that you're now in front of everybody and you've gotten the advice
from people and now you want to start talking in the room about the advice.
Do not say who you think should be hired because that'll ruin the whole thing.
Right?
So like keep,
keep your own beliefs to yourself when you're trying to get advice from other
people.
Eat.
And this is a simple like in everyday life.
If I read an article on politics when,
if I'm asking you what your opinion of the article is,
I should not say what my belief about that is because then I've ruined the whole
thing.
Right.
So I think that that's really what you should do with it.
It's kind of like unless you've got a large enough end,
which is rare,
you should kind of leave it out where to where to outcomes help you.
Well you know obviously throughout your life as you kind of get them in,
they might be prompts for you to go in and say,
well maybe I should look at the decision quality,
but it should be both.
In the case of whether you won or loss,
it should be a prompt to go in and look at the decision quality and when you go
in and look at the decision quality and you go want to talk to other people
about it,
you're going to do better because you've been prompted by the outcome to leave
the outcome out as you're going to actually improve the decision quality.
It's a little counter intuitive,
but no,
there isn't.
There's some situations where just sitting out and not making a decision.
Make Sense.
Cause you mentioned that most poker players,
like 80% of the hands,
they don't make any actions on his like 20th they play.
Yeah.
So,
um,
it's,
so in poker,
one of the biggest mistakes that people make is actually playing way too many
hands.
Um,
and you always need to think about when you're actually going to enter into
something you need to be selective.
So I want to talk about sort of both sides of this puzzle.
Um,
one is that just doing stuff isn't enough.
Like I may think a lot of times people are like,
just throw a lot of spaghetti against the wall,
but you should actually think about each strand and make sure you're getting a
payoff for the strand.
So,
uh,
the fact is yes,
if you throw a bunch of Spaghetti against the wall,
some of that will pay off in some of it won't.
But like,
and I think that people look at that and they look at like for example,
vcs and they think what,
that's what their strategy is,
that they're just sort of like playing every hand and then some of them pay off
and you know when they pay off,
they're really happy.
But that's not true.
They're there.
They are spreading their bets across a large basket,
but they're actually vetting each of the bets that they're making to make sure
that they,
given what they know,
they think that the payoff is going to be big enough.
So that's similar to what a poker player does.
So that's number one.
But then number two that I think is really important to think about is that
don't take that to the point of thinking that somehow making a decision is
substantively different from not making a decision because they're both
decisions.
So you have whatever the status quo is and when you're going along and just kind
of going with the status quo,
trust me,
you're making a decision every single time you do that.
So I think that when we're trying to sort of think about doing these scenario
plans and imagining what the future might look like,
we only think about it in terms of decisions that we think are new.
We're somehow,
we're changing course but not changing courses,
a decision in and of itself.
So you should be taking time frequently to look at what the status quo is,
to look at what you're doing,
the strategies that you've always just kind of been applying and do the exact
same kind of analysis on that as if it were a new decision.
So let me give you like a super simple example.
So like the simplest example ever,
you're in a grocery store and there's like,
you know,
six lanes open and you're Einstein at this moment.
Like you're literally doing some kind of quantum physics analysis about which
line you're supposed to get into.
You're laughing because you know it's true.
So it's like,
you know,
you're looking for the lady with the coupons and you know,
the cashier that looks maybe like,
you know,
oh he's,
he seems a little slow,
or he's newer,
he's a trainee.
Or,
you know,
the person who has 17,000 things in their cart versus,
whatever.
I mean you're,
it's like literally like you are completely calculating this stuff out.
Okay,
so now,
so because that's a new decision,
right?
So you're like calculating out all the scenarios,
trying to figure out like which is going to give me the best future because
you're now investing your time,
right?
So this is like,
this is very clearly a bet you're betting on a line and you think that the you,
that results from choosing whatever line it is that you go to,
it's going to save time over the you that results from whatever other line you
might choose.
So that's like your,
and that's what most bets are.
You're not betting against other people,
you're betting against other versions of yourself,
right?
Like Annie that chooses lie a versus anti that chooses line be or like I'm in
the restaurant Andy that chooses the chicken or anti that chooses the fish or
whatever.
So anti that chooses demoine Moines versus anti that chooses Las Vegas.
Okay.
So now you choose a line and you get in the line and the line turns out to be
slow.
What do you do?
Not you stay in the line,
right?
You don't move.
But it's a new decision.
Like once you figure out the line is slow switch,
but you don't because you know why?
Because you're worried about like,
now if I switch,
what if that line,
my line starts moving faster,
I'll feel like I made a mistake.
But at any moment it's the same decision.
So if you treat the status quo as if like,
that's not a decision in and of itself,
what happens is you actually end up not changing course enough.
So I this actually,
we can go back to the Pete Carroll example to think about this.
Um,
let's do the other thought experiment where Pete Carroll just doesn't change as
grocery line,
right?
So he hands it off to Marshawn Lynch,
That was the expected play.
That's the status quo play.
And let's say he doesn't score.
What do you think the headlines look like the next day?
A New England's good.
Like,
literally,
nobody's like,
oh he's the worst coach in Superbowl history cause he handed up to Marshawn
lynch and he didn't score.
Why?
Because people aren't viewing that as a decision,
right?
Like that's just the status quo.
We already have consensus around that.
Clearly if he doesn't win,
then it's not the decision quality.
Now we can firmly stick it in the luck bucket because nobody's questioning the
status quo.
So now I must be something that's outside of his control.
So included in luck would be some,
for example,
the quality of the defensive line of New England would be included in luck.
Luck is anything you don't that you yourself don't control.
Okay.
So and that's because like all right,
he chose his grocery line,
like he's not switching.
So the reason why Pete Carroll got so,
um,
demolished in that decision is because he switched grocery lines.
But he was right to do that.
Like that's how progress gets made.
I find her daily life too.
Sometimes as a result happens,
we'll look at the person who made a decision and then we'll say to herself,
well,
if they went their way,
then odds are it's luck.
But if it would have failed,
it's like,
you know,
it's mostly due to their like incompetencies or whatnot.
Um,
do we,
is there mechanisms where we can be more like cognizant of that when we fall in
to that mode?
Yeah.
So I,
so I,
I've talked about this particular thing resulting,
which is where we like really tightly connect outcomes and decisions.
So,
but there's two ways that we do this.
One is like we're looking at someone from afar,
like Pete Carroll.
Okay.
So he's not in our reference group,
right?
Like we don't compare ourselves to him.
And so that case we just looked like bad outcome means bad decision.
Good outcome means a good decision.
So it's interesting cause we do a pattern for ourselves.
It's a little bit different.
So if anybody's read thinking fast and slow from Daniel Conoman,
you'll remember from this,
from this,
that we're really trying to drive a positive narrative or of our lives,
right?
We want to think that we're good actors and we're smart and so on,
so forth.
So obviously,
um,
this goes in the motivated reasoning category.
Like if we have a bad outcome for ourselves,
if I lose a hand at poker that doesn't really jive with this positive self
narrative,
at least not in the moment.
Okay.
So then what do we do?
Now remember we've got this noise in the system,
right?
We got the hidden information and luck when I have a bad,
when I lose a hand at poker,
it's because of luck.
When I went ahead and had pokers cause I'm a genius.
Um,
that's called self serving bias.
I feel it feel like it's pretty self explanatory name for that particular bias.
Um,
and we do this in all areas of our lives.
When someone gets a promotion,
um,
you know,
it's not,
it's bad luck for us.
Like it's not like we didn't do the work or we didn't,
you know,
obviously we deserved it.
It was just like bad luck.
It wasn't in our control.
Actually car car accidents are an interesting place to look.
Over.
90% of a two car accidents are reported as the other person's fault.
Um,
this is a pretty good one.
I think it's 37%.
I think of single car accidents as reported as not the person's fault.
I don't know.
You go figure that one out.
So that's how strong this biases right now.
What's interesting is it,
but the number of decisions that we make in our lives is obviously much less
than the number of decisions we're able to observe and other people.
So let's assume that we were okay were crappy for ourselves,
but it doesn't matter cause then we get to feel good about ourselves.
But we're really good at analyzing everybody else's decisions.
But the problem is as soon as someone's in our reference group,
as soon as some,
it's someone that we feel like we're comparing ourselves to sort of figure out
what our self worth is because we don't do that.
Our happiness doesn't derive an absence of the way that we compare to other
people.
Now what we do is the reverse pattern,
right?
When they do something good,
it's because they got lucky.
And when they do something bad,
it's because they're a really bad decision maker.
So when they,
uh,
you know,
when a hand of poker,
it's because they got lucky and when they lose a hand of poker it's because
they're a bad decision maker.
Now you can kind of see actually if you think about poker,
which is zero sum,
how these two problems might have emerged,
right?
Because looking at a zero sum game like poker,
you can see how that pattern happens.
So if I'm trying to offload my bad results to luck and I lose a hand
specifically to you,
I can't say that you won the hand because of skill that doesn't work.
So I have to say that you lost the hand because of luck.
Cause cause I'm trying to put my bat,
you know,
I'm trying to say it's bad luck for me.
So therefore it must be good.
Look for you.
And if I win a hand because of lot of skill rather,
I can't say that you lost because of luck.
It doesn't jive.
It's just that,
you know,
so we sort of treat everything like it's zero Sam,
like when we shouldn't,
but you can see how that happens when I specifically think I'm referring to you
when you're in my reference group.
So again,
like how do we,
how do we solve for this?
Well I'm going to go back to that group idea form a really,
really good decision group that has different values.
So there's different ways that we can derive good feelings from ourselves,
right?
So our natural tendency is to try to offload it in the moment so that we don't
have to have a negative update to our self image and we don't ever miss out on a
positive update to our self image.
Right?
Because if I say that I won because I got lucky,
I don't get that positive update.
And if I say that I lost because of something I did,
And that sort of the natural way that were like getting our pellets,
like we're pressing a lever in a Skinner box is that that's where appellate's
are coming from.
But very early in my poker career,
I went up to somebody named Erik Seidel,
has an amazing poker player,
is one over $38 million in his career.
So he's really,
really good.
I had met him when I was actually 16,
and I didn't start playing poker professionally until I was 26,
so he was just like a buddy of mine.
Um,
and then all of a sudden I'm 26 and now he's a professional peer.
So I remember I was in a tournament,
I got knocked out,
you know,
and obviously something unlucky happened to me clearly.
Um,
and I went up to Eric Sydell and I went to go what's called moaning.
I went to go complain to him about,
I can't believe this.
I had such bad luck.
I had this hand and hey man,
uh,
the normal,
and he actually laid this out for me.
How do we solve for this?
And like the most beautiful way,
it's going to sound kind of brutal,
but I'm so thankful for it.
So why are you telling me this?
Like,
you think I'm not losing myself?
why are you offloading your negative emotions onto me?
I don't need that.
If you really lost because of bad luck,
there's nothing to be learned from it.
So I would like you to not offload your emotional distress onto me.
Thank you very much.
However,
if you have a question,
if there's something that you're trying to ask me about strategy,
I'm all ears.
So let's think about what he did there.
He said,
if you're not focusing on accuracy,
I don't care.
What does that mean?
This focus on accuracy.
Let's think about the division division,
division between the distinction between,
uh,
reasoning to be accurate and reasoning to be right.
Reasoning to be right is I just want my priors to be right.
So I'm just going to reason to prove that I'm right all the time,
right reasoning to be accurate.
That's funny that I said right,
right after that,
um,
reasoning to be accurate is I'm trying to construct the most accurate model of
the objective truth.
And if you think about who's going to win in a bat,
the person who's reasoning to be right versus the person who's reason it'd be
accurate.
That's why when I say do you do want to bet,
it takes you out of the right mode,
right into the accurate mode because everybody understands,
like if I'm going to bet on it,
I better be reasoning to be accurate.
So he told me,
you have to be reasoning to be accurate.
What you're doing right now is reasoning.
If we write you're sad,
you lost,
it's not your fault,
blah,
blah.
That doesn't,
that doesn't help anybody.
But if you have a question,
if you want to know whether you accurately played the hand,
let's talk about it.
So he told me that the,
that I have to think about accuracy if I'm talking to him,
he told me he was to be,
hold me accountable to that because he did.
In that moment he was holding me accountable to the way I was thinking.
And he said,
you're going to have to be open to maybe things aren't the way that you want
them to be.
So I was going to have to be open to diverse opinions and other people's
perspectives.
So let's take those three things.
There's a great group charter,
right?
You have to have a focus on accuracy of commitment to accuracy.
You have to hold each other accountable to these things and you have to be open
to diverse viewpoints.
That seems like a pretty good charter.
And what's really wonderful about what Eric did for me in that moment,
we remained friends cause I was thankful for this.
Um,
I was a little upset in the moment,
but I got over it.
I,
I saw it,
I saw the value eventually.
Um,
but what he did for me was two things.
One is now I understood that when I went and talked to him,
he was going to mentor me,
he was going to teach me how to play.
So when I had hand questions I could actually deconstruct them with him and that
was going to be super helpful for me.
So that was a little bit of the help.
But the big help he gave me was when I went back and played on my own.
So when you're playing poker,
it's all on your own.
I was processing what was happening at the table differently,
so I'm not processing.
Oh,
I got unlucky.
I'm so smart.
Oh,
I got unlucky.
I'm so smart because that's not good material for me to go back to Eric with.
Right.
And I know later on he's going to hold me accountable and if I want to have a
really good discussion with him,
I have to come to them with good material.
So now it changes the way that I'm viewing what's happening at the table in the
moment so that I'm looking for mistakes.
I'm looking for questions,
I'm looking for other people where other people might be out playing me,
where they might be winning because they're better than I am and I'm going to go
tell him and now this is what happens.
This is so great.
Two great things happen from that thing.
Number one,
I go back to them and I say,
you know what?
I think I really butchered a hand.
I think I really made a mistake and he gives me a pellet,
right?
So he wasn't giving me pellets for pressing the luck.
You know,
I just got unlucky lever,
right?
He's giving me pellets for the,
I think I made a mistake lever.
So that's really great.
So that,
now that becomes part of myself narrative,
right?
Eric Sydell wants to talk to me.
He thinks I'm smart,
right?
So I'm getting those.
I'm getting,
I wouldn't,
I'm not like I practice mindfulness,
but I don't think I'm ever achieving like the,
you know,
on the mountain in Tibet,
not worried about what the world thinks of me.
I'm trying,
but I'm not going to get there.
So Eric Sydell is giving me that,
right?
He's,
he's helping me to think better by giving me the right kind of pellet.
Right?
That's number one.
And then number two,
again,
back to the,
I'm trying to be a monk on top of a mountain in Tibet.
I'm really trying hard for that mindfulness,
that,
that ultimate mindfulness practice.
But,
um,
I'm kind of failing at and I'm just,
but I'm working on it.
I'm trying,
I'm practicing it.
But in the meantime,
if we go back to that tribalism and how does our tribe feel distinct from
others?
Think about what it did for me when I walked up to Eric and my group and I was
saying,
I really think I made a mistake,
but when I'm walking down the hall of the Poker Room,
I'm hearing all these people go,
can you believe how unlucky I got ya?
I got so unlucky to,
yeah,
oh,
that an idiot,
Dah,
Dah.
And that's what those tribes are,
how they are talking to each other.
So I got my distinctiveness in the mix too.
So it was like I got my cake and I got to eat it too,
which was kind of good.
And then in the meantime,
I'm doing a mindfulness practice and trying not to worry about any of that,
but until I can't,
you know,
until I get there,
I get to reinforce all of these good,
you know,
changes and cognitive style through what the group is giving me.
So I want to ask you one more question before I go to the audience.
Um,
it seems like what you're,
you're talking about,
it's not just applicable to the poker world.
No,
it's for sure not.
I see the investment world.
I see family,
things like that.
Where have you seen these skills kind of like spill over for you and your life?
Oh my gosh.
Uh,
everywhere.
Um,
so I want to say two things.
One is this,
these skills have definitely spilled over in all areas of my life and I'm
terrible at them.
Um,
so the,
the thing is like these,
the,
this,
the way that we process information is so built in that our goal is really to be
a little bit better at it.
Um,
and if you're a little bit better at it,
it's going to compound over time.
It's going to really make a difference in your overall decision quality and the
quality of the outcomes that you eventually have.
So I still mess up all the time.
Trust me.
Bad things have to me.
I go,
I can blue that.
Oh,
so unlucky.
It's just that I catch myself hopefully more often and hopefully a little bit
faster than I otherwise would.
But I know I'm still missing a lot of those.
I mean,
I'm still biased,
so that's number one.
But number two,
in terms of areas of my life,
like everywhere,
so like in the way that I parent my children and the way that I talked to my
partner and the way that I,
the process of writing this book,
you know,
where you have to be like you're working with an editor and you have to not sort
of like push off what they're saying because you feel so much ownership over the
word words and you know better than they do.
It's like trying to have open mindedness and really use the editor and your
agent and so and so forth.
It's like that kind of truth seeking group that you're trying to come up with
the best representation of your ideas.
And that's not necessarily all the ideas of how you think it should be
presented,
that you have to be open minded to that.
Um,
you know,
just like I say,
like in terms of the way that I talk to my kids and I guide my kids,
like I,
you know,
every teenager that has,
I've raised is,
comes back from school.
I can't believe I did so bad on the test is because the teacher was mean.
And they gave me things that they didn't even teach in class and it was really
hard.
And you can ask anybody,
right?
So like how are you talking to somebody about that?
And um,
you know,
saying,
well with kids it's,
it's,
you don't want to be challenging them in the same way,
but you say,
okay,
that's,
I'm sorry about that.
So what are you going to do about that?
Like in the future,
how do you think you're going to solve for that?
So really trying to get them to understand like what are the things that are
under your control and what aren't.
So not in an Eric Sydell way,
but trying to say like,
okay,
how can you do better?
Like,
how can you make it so that maybe you should go talk to the teacher,
you know,
before the next test,
if,
you know,
they might put things on the test that they didn't teach.
So like that,
you know,
not so much disagreeing with them because I'm not,
they're not adults.
Um,
but trying to get them to focus more on those things that are in their control.
But also just in terms of like when I was writing the book,
I was thinking like,
okay,
it's going to be a certain amount of time that I'm going to have to invest what,
you know,
am I going to get,
what am I going to get in return?
What does the future look like?
Like I thought about the book could be a total flop.
I have to think about that in advance.
And is that going to feel okay for me?
Is it going to be worthwhile to have written the book even if nobody ever reads
it?
Um,
so it's like really kind of everywhere.
and then,
you know,
really recognizing.
The other thing is I'm a big believer in Ulysses contracts because I really
understand that as much as you.
Yeah,
sorry.
you're right.
I'm assuming.
Um,
so Ulysses contract is thinking in advance about places where,
you know,
you're going to be really biased and it's going to be hard to overcome this,
um,
in order to kind of prevent yourself from acting irrationally.
So we don't always have a group of other people around us to help us,
but you can actually form a different kind of group,
which is a,
a group of the past versions of you in the future versions of you to all kind of
come to help gather and help the present version of you.
So the classic example is from Greek literature.
Odysseus was,
you know,
sailing along and he knew he was going to come to the island of the sirens.
And the sirens were these beautiful Nims that sang on the shore.
And the song was so irresistible to the ears of any man that they would steer
their ship toward the shore.
The shore was a rocky shoals that would break the ship apart,
sudden death.
So,
uh,
Ulysses,
which is the Roman name for Odysseus,
knew this and asked his crew to tie his hands to the mast of the ship.
So this is a really good example of forming a group that's different versions of
you.
So,
uh,
Odysseus said future Odysseus is really going to have a problem cause future
Odysseus is going to steer toward the shore.
So I'm going to tie future Odysseus's hands to stop him from doing that.
So I think there's all sorts of places where you can recognize,
um,
that you might need help in the future.
Like a simple example would be take a ride sharing service to a bar.
Um,
that's a way to tie your hands.
I,
you know,
for me with exercising,
I sign up for classes in advance so that I've got my schedule worked out and I
feel that some,
you know,
that I have a commitment to that.
Um,
I only have certain kinds of foods in the house.
you know,
these are all examples of,
of Ulysses contracts and I'm a huge fan of those and I apply those across my
whole life,
including actually in writing the book,
which was instead of,
uh,
instead of ever letting my editor set the deadline for me,
um,
because that is more like someone telling me what to do,
which doesn't feel this as like a contract.
I said all my own deadlines.
So I,
I would tell her what day,
um,
I actually would usually give her three days in a confidence interval around
each one
because,
you know,
well obviously cause I wrote this book,
So,
uh,
so it would be with it,
but there would be a week that I would know that I had to turn it in.
And I would say,
you know,
Monday,
it's 60% on Monday and 80% Tuesday and I'm 98% on Friday.
So,
um,
so by setting that myself,
I was creating a contract.
Um,
and then,
you know,
I held to the deadline and actually got the book in early because I was,
uh,
because I was applying Ulysses contracts.
So I really do practice what I preached in the book.
It's an excellent concept and I'm just realizing,
oh my God,
I didn't see that because I was writing a letter to someone and I was making a
reference to the sirens in their songs.
So that's excellent.
Do we have any audience questions?
Let's start here.
Cause I,
I you were my poker opponent and then I'll move across the line.
Oh,
I need a gray zone.
Have you here?
My wife is a big a fan.
Oh,
thank you.
So I'll come in from China.
I just nod his,
your career path is a very kind of a interest to team from academia,
the important player.
Now you change out other causes.
So what kind of,
uh,
you,
you talk about decision making,
right?
Just for your life,
based on your life with your parents were kind of bad or big.
So it was kind of a,
when you make those the season,
you know what you did,
you know it's a naturally come to that,
the season or it's a,
sometime you really think about that urinates you know,
blog sometime and the okay,
I need to change.
So yeah,
that's basically
hi.
So that,
that's an interesting question.
So yeah,
I mean I have taken a lot of turns and I actually think that my life is a good
example of I really understanding kind of,
you know,
this luck versus decision quality.
So I would say that the two big career careers that I've had have come out of
some,
something happens.
It's either sort of on the face of it looks lucky or unlucky,
but it's definitely an intervention of love.
And then I just say,
okay,
here I am now let me think about what,
what,
where I'm going to go from here.
So it's not sort of sitting and wallowing in the,
in the,
in the sort of luck element of it,
but just thinking,
okay,
I'm here now,
so now,
all right,
that's done.
I've got to sort of figure out where to go from here.
So the first one would be this illness Atlanta,
me in the hospital for two weeks.
I still sometimes struggle with it,
but you know,
I've got,
it's an,
it was very out of control at that time and now I've got it under control so it
doesn't intervene in my life in the same way anymore.
But this was when I was really struggling with the stomach issue.
I land in the hospital for two weeks.
This seems like an incredibly unlucky thing that's happened to me.
And I say,
okay,
I need money.
What am I going to do?
I don't have my fellowship anymore.
It turns out that when you leave graduate school and take time off the NSF,
the National Science Foundation doesn't still give you money.
So all right,
I got to figure out what I'm going to do.
And that's when I started playing poker.
And then when I was playing poker I discovered okay,
like I'm pretty good at it and I really enjoy it.
And it seemed like this really cool like collision of what I was studying.
And academics and sort of real life.
Right?
And so,
and,
and at that point I said,
okay,
I'm just going to delay graduate school and this is what I did.
Once I started poker,
I didn't necessarily think there was something else I was going to do.
Then I got asked to give this talk in 2002 it was great and I still didn't
think,
and that was a matter of luck because Eric Sydell actually ask God,
ask the good the give the talk,
not me.
And he hates public speaking.
So he referred me.
This had nothing to do with me.
I wasn't seeking it out.
Right?
This was not a decision I made.
I get offered the talk.
I say yes,
I give it.
And I'm still thinking,
oh,
that was fun.
Except that the person,
the people that I give the talk to started referring me out.
At which point I said,
okay,
now I've got a choice.
Like I've got a choice.
I could,
maybe I could do this as well,
which I did.
So,
and there's been all sorts of,
there's other points in my life.
I almost became an options trader a little while after that.
But then poker got on TV and I thought that's kind of interesting.
Maybe I'll try that.
And I think that because I think probabilistically I end up,
I'm just less likely to stick with the status quo.
I'm more likely to say,
okay,
it's a new decision.
Do I want to switch grocery lines?
Um,
and so I think that's sort of how I end up looking like I'm kind of here or here
or here.
It's just okay,
luck brings you to certain places and I'm perfectly fine saying here's the
status quo and here's this new thing that I can do.
What can I do?
Or maybe I can do them both at the same time.
I think I tend to be more open minded maybe to that because that's the thing
that poker really teaches you.
It's like the best laid plans,
right?
You still lose the hand and so it forces you to think probabilistically you have
to be thinking this way or you will not succeed.
And I think naturally it spreads out here.
Here is the actual funniest example that I can give you of how poker players
just really think this way.
Um,
so,
uh,
when I went to go on my first date with the absolute love of my life,
my brother and brother in law who both knew the person that was going on the
first date with immediately set a market.
So,
so they started bidding.
We'd never been on a date.
We had been friends for a long time,
but we've never been on a date.
So they,
they start bidding.
And my brother in law ended up buying 23,
so somebody said to me,
aren't you offended that they started making a market?
And I was like,
no,
I just,
I just can't believe my brother in law bought 23,
like we'd never been on a date.
So I think that that shows you,
it's like just this way of thinking about the world,
just sort of a,
you know,
attaching numbers to it.
And,
um,
and that's why I think that I sort of,
you know,
I hope that answers your question.
Our next question is online.
Okay.
Um,
you've talked about the feeling like an imposter or outsider,
some poker tables.
What are some of the ways the ideas in your book can help address the imposture
syndrome sensation or counteract overconfidence?
Yeah,
yeah,
that's,
that's actually really good.
So I think the overconfidence piece is a little bit easier to deal with because
I think that if you have a really good decision group,
they're going to check your overconfidence.
Um,
so that's going to be part of the conversation all the time.
Is,
is,
are you feeling overconfident?
Um,
imposter syndrome,
you know,
it's,
it's a hard one.
I mean,
I feel it all the time.
I,
I feel it about this book.
I feel it when I get up and give talks.
It's like,
oh,
well,
you know,
why am I even opening my mouth?
Um,
and I,
I think that again,
it's like get other people to talk to you,
you know,
because what they can do is they can often see things more clearly.
So I've actually had conversations where I said,
you know,
oh,
I just feel like I can't believe it.
I'm such an imposter.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Data.
And people will say like,
people keep hiring you for speeches.
They'll actually go through it like,
you know,
they refer you out,
people are buying your book.
They're obviously,
you know,
and having other people to kind of look at you in a more objective way to get
you out of your own head.
I think I really feel like that's the way to do it.
And then what happens is it's like,
I highly recommend everybody read the power of habit because it really shows you
how to change your habits,
but not just,
not just the habits of like going to the gym,
like your habits of mind and the way you think.
And what ends up is,
you know,
remember I said when I had that conversation with Eric Sydell,
now when I went to the table,
I was thinking about what Eric Sydell might say later.
And so when you have a really good decision group that's checking your bias,
whether it's over confidence or under confidence or imposter syndrome,
the group gets in your head and a really good way.
So that then when I'm sort of on my own and I'm like,
trust me,
when I leave this room and I'm in the car,
I'm going to think about what a bad talk I gave.
So maybe I did,
I don't know.
I just,
so now I'm in my head.
Um,
okay.
So anyway,
uh,
when I do that,
hopefully I have a group of people that I can sort of offload that to and they
can offload things like that to me.
And hopefully they're talking to me.
I mean not physically,
but the,
I'm sort of running that conversation,
you know,
cause that's really what happened at the poker table was if I,
if I was processing the world and like a way that was irrational,
I would run the conversation with Eric or my brother or John Hennigan or whoever
it might be later where they were telling me like,
oh,
come on.
Um,
and that would help me when I was kind of on my own.
So I think it's about how are you,
how,
what are the rewards are getting and how are people around you helping to sort
of shape,
you know,
those,
those habits of mind.
And I think that's really the best way.
Cause I think it's just the thing is I think it's so hard to do on your own.
I just think,
I think we all really need help with this.
You know,
and I think another,
another mistake we make is we think,
well,
if I know about it,
like if I know about imposter syndrome or I know about overconfidence and I'm
really smart,
problem solved
in the book.
Didn't you mentioned that the people who have the highest Iq scores are the ones
you're most susceptible to.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
being uh,
actually being high Iq correlates positively with motivated reasoning.
So,
uh,
it,
right.
And you can think why that is,
right?
It's like how do you slice and dice the info?
Like if you're cognitively agile,
you're going to be able to slice and dice the story.
That sounds a lot more convincing to yourself and to others about why everything
you believe is true and why every prediction you'll have is 100%.
Um,
so yeah,
so I'm smart and I know about this now is not necessarily a solution.
And like I say,
like I,
I'm telling you,
I'm going to walk away from this.
I'm going to think about what a bad job I did.
I'm not,
I don't want you guys to think that like you,
you,
you practice these things and somehow it's ever solved.
It's not,
it's just do I catch myself doing it more often?
Do I do it less?
And those,
just doing it less and catching it more often is,
it's huge.
So instead of like berating yourself for all the times that you screw up,
it's like you get to celebrate that I did at one fewer times.
You know,
like it's,
it's such a more self compassionate way to live.
Like,
and I'm really like,
I'm trying to get there,
but you know.
Yeah.
So I think you had a question.
Oh,
sorry.
What are we supposed to end up?
Sorry,
I didn't want to keep going.
We're okay.
Yeah.
Okay,
sure.
Question.
What's your strategy for Rock,
paper scissors?
Oh,
Short,
short answer is throw scissors.
Um,
so just kind of understand.
So most people throw rock first.
Um,
and then most people kind of know you throw a rock.
So,
um,
so,
uh,
what happens is,
well,
it depends if you're against somebody who is a total newbie,
so you know they're gonna Throw Rock,
um,
uh,
then you should,
you know,
just throw paper.
But,
but if you're against somebody who you think is a little bit smarter than that,
they're going to throw a paper on you.
So you do a pretty good job throwing scissors.
And if they're really good,
they throw scissors,
a new tie.
So it's not a big deal.
Oh,
one of the things that you said at the beginning of the talk,
like really stuck with me about like,
uh,
talking about your opinions and in terms of bets and challenging that,
how'd you do that when something isn't quite as quantifiable as like the number
of representatives in the house in November?
Sure.
So everything can be quantified.
The chances that you,
because every,
everything is probabilistic.
Like the chances that you meet the love of your life tomorrow or that the person
that you stay with,
you'll still be within 10 years.
Or whether you're going to like the dish that you order at a restaurant or
literally,
you know,
literally everything is quantifiable.
Now,
do we have enough data to get to a flipping heads or tails where we know,
we know 50% of the time that you're gonna flip heads?
No,
I,
is there some objective probability for anything?
Sure.
Do we have access to it?
Absolutely not.
But we can sort of come up with a range now.
So what people will say to me is often,
well,
it's not really quantifiable.
Well,
of course it is.
It's just that it's harder.
There's more unknown information.
It's harder to get to.
We don't have as much data.
So what I tell them is,
look,
let's say that I were to ask you some question about,
well,
what do you think the chances are that this belief that you have is true?
Um,
and the best you could do is somewhere between 20 and 80%.
Right?
That's a really wide market.
But you know what?
It's not as wide as zero to a hundred.
Like at least you're trying.
That's the thing.
Even if you say,
I don't know,
I can narrow it down to between 20 and 80%,
that's not a failure.
That's a success because you're trying,
and then what that does is because you've,
you,
you say,
well,
okay,
it's 28,
80%,
man,
I'd really like to try to refine that.
You'll now start to go ask people like,
you're going to go start asking for information.
You're,
whereas if you just sort of leave it as like whatever,
you don't actually ever tried to get better at it.
So now maybe you go and you start researching and you w,
you know what,
I make a joke and it literally every single talk that I give,
I say,
what this does for you that makes you take out and look at Google,
you guys will be very having to it.
But literally it's a joke in every time in every talk that I give,
it makes me want to Google things.
Um,
so,
but it makes me want to Google things.
So,
so now you start googling and maybe you,
you say,
okay,
now I'm there down,
it's between 72% and,
right.
So like that's what happens.
You know,
now it's 70 to 28.
Um,
so,
and now you're a little bit narrower than,
than 80,
20,
and that's all we're trying to do.
But if we don't think about things probabilistically,
if we don't recognize that what's going to happen in the future is
probabilistic,
that we can't guarantee it.
We are not playing chess.
If I play better than you,
it does not mean I win.
Not In life,
only in chess,
right?
That if we don't do that,
then we're going to be really surprised when a bad outcome happens.
We're going to overreact to it.
We're,
we're going to start changing strategy when we shouldn't.
We're going to reinforce strategies that we shouldn't.
We're going to always be reacting instead of planning ahead instead of being
proactive because we're not understanding that well,
other things would happen then the thing that we think,
you know,
so I think just try,
just try like,
cause every,
literally everything is quantifiable.
Um,
where were you at on Black Friday in 2011.
And what are your thoughts on regulating online poker?
Oh,
okay.
That's an interesting question.
So where I was at,
I remember this,
I was in my bedroom,
uh,
and I got a call.
You should open up the internet and you should look.
Um,
so black Friday is the DOJ came in down and shut down all of online poker.
It was a very bad day for poker.
Everybody was really mad.
It was,
it was really hard.
Like in a lot of ways,
the poker community hasn't recovered from it.
So it was kind of interesting because,
uh,
I played in the 90s when,
in poker,
money was not raining down from the sky.
Um,
uh,
you know,
there was a very small group of people who were playing and they need sometimes
have,
you know,
someone who came in and would play and you know,
you were,
it was really like you were,
it was called grinding and then online poker happened with the collision of
poker on TV and the poker economy just boomed.
I mean,
I mean boomed.
It was really like just money raining down from the sky and then the DOJ on
black Friday,
now it all contracts and that was really hard.
I think it was less hard for the people who had been playing in the 90s,
because I think we sort of saw the luck in what had happened during the two
thousands a little bit more.
Um,
but it's like whenever anything goes through like a big recession and I would
call it a depression.
It's painful,
right?
Like it's super,
super,
super painful.
Um,
you know,
in,
in terms of whether there should be regulation,
um,
you know,
I'm somewhat small government,
but I'm also,
you know,
I like people to have protections.
So I did testify in front of Congress twice about regulation and um,
um,
I tend to be more on the sort of free for your side of that discussion.
Um,
you know that you should let adults choose what they want to do and then
obviously make sure that there isn't fraud occurring.
Right.
So you,
so you should always have protections against fraud.
Excellent.
What resonated with me?
You Christina,
status quo.
Yeah.
I think it's uh,
it's great because it gives you a lot of opportunity to see your options in life
all the time instead of just going with what you have.
But also I have,
the feeling is a,
it's a risky business.
You know,
you can like invest a lot of time and always questioning your set of school and
instead of focusing on what you're doing and like trusting your decisions you
made in the past and like,
how do you find the balance,
you know,
and you seem to have been going good places of it.
So do you set your set of,
you know,
mine stores,
Oh,
I'm questioning where I'm at in life next month from now?
Or do you like two minutes later when you're on the wrong line?
I mean,
you know,
how much time do you invest in that bed too?
I think there's a couple of things.
I think certainly from a business standpoint,
we always go,
you know,
there's always strategic planning sessions and I think that when we do that,
it's always around like,
what's the new decision and what doesn't get included in there as well?
What about sticking with what we're doing?
Um,
so I think that we tend to,
uh,
get involved in strategic planning decisions generally when there's something
wrong and you should actually set a calendar for,
all right,
let's,
let's start thinking about what are our goals regardless of whether we think
something is wrong,
because maybe there's a better way to do it.
Um,
uh,
and,
and actually working backwards is,
so something called backcasting and premortems is the best way to do that.
So imagine what your goal is.
Think about that.
You've actually reached it.
This is a backcast.
And then think about how you got to the,
how you actually did it.
So it's three years from now and you know,
we accomplished x,
how did we do that?
But then also a premortem is it's three years from now and we failed.
You know,
how did that happen?
Um,
and I think that allows you to see the landscape a little bit better.
what I would say in terms of,
you know,
are you doing it too much or are you doing it too little?
Um,
there,
there's two things that I want to say about that.
One is that I certainly don't think that every decision that you're ever
supposed to be make is,
Eh,
is supposed to be done as a deliberative process if you did that,
I wouldn't be able to get from here to there.
Right?
So,
uh,
a lot of stuff that's happening is certainly more gut and it's more in the
moment.
And I think that that's totally fine as long as you hold your intuition
accountable to a deliberative process at some point.
So when somebody says to you,
well why did you do what you did?
Uh,
your answer never be because my gut told me to.
And then when they say,
okay,
that's great,
but why?
It shouldn't be because I told you because my gut told me to.
If you can't teach it to another PR person,
there was a problem.
So that being said,
I think intuition can be very good as long as you're checking it occasionally.
Um,
but in terms of whether you should have a schedule,
I think once you start thinking about the world more probabilistic,
Lee,
you're naturally examining those things and it's happening relatively
automatically and you do end up sticking with the status quo a lot.
It's just that you're sort of seeing these opportunities over on the side more.
Now,
what's interesting is that when you do that,
you don't just overreact and like just because things aren't going well right
now,
you're actually less likely I think to change course because I think that a lot
of our changing courses,
a reaction to the way that the status quo is,
is now it's a reaction to having a bad outcome and a lot of not changing courses
that we just happened to have good outcomes.
So I think that what happens is that when you start thinking in this way more
probabilistically,
even if you have good outcomes,
you are,
you're always sort of working with your decision group of like,
well,
is there a better way?
That doesn't necessarily mean you do it,
it just means it's,
it's in your head so that you're,
you're more likely to sort of see the opportunity when it comes your way.
But what's more important is you're less likely to overreact to a bad outcome
happening where you actually change course too much.
And I would actually say that interestingly enough that that second problem is
what the big problem,
the bigger problem is.
It's not so much that if you think this way,
you're,
you're going to be going left,
right,
left,
right.
It's that you're not going to be just going left because bad things are
happening all the time.
You're going to be setting back into a more deliberative place on those things.
It's actually going to either cause you to make sort of incremental changes that
are going to be really good.
It's going to cause you to be able to anticipate or think about paradigm shifts
for yourself a little bit better and I think it's going to actually give you a
smoother ride,
much,
much more so than a less smooth ride and I don't know.
Not See now.
Now you might go and say,
no,
she should actually get into that limo and how to do that.
Does that answer your question
on the other
side?
Yeah.
No,
I'm for,
I'm all for status quo.
Yeah.
Do you see the,
you see the success and you wanted,
they always question it was just as you've met yesterday.
Well,
yeah,
so I think it's like again,
it has to do,
right?
It has to do with separating those,
those that don't Pat Yourself.
I sort of say don't get so down on yourself for your bad outcomes and don't pat
yourself on the back so hard for your good ones.
So like here's a really great way actually the to implement within your own
life.
It's like once a week have a team,
your team get together.
Think of each person presents like the best success that they had that week.
And everybody talks about like they have to offer up the five things that they
did wrong along the way to that success.
So it's not about changing course,
right?
It's about,
it's more about refining,
about always trying to do a little bit better.
And I think that when you have that goal in mind,
I think you do a lot better cause otherwise it's what makes us make these big
left turns.
I mean,
I mean I've got a couple in my life,
but um,
you know,
what makes us make these big left turns,
I think is when we're reacting to the way that things are,
we're just reacting.
So when you're trying to separate these two things at and always be trying to
focus on process,
now what happens is you're less likely to be making these like 90 degree
changes,
I think.
Oh,
I have an online question.
Okay.
What is your approach to the mental game of poker when running bad,
when our emotions can potentially influence our thought process?
Can you compare that to the advice offered by Jared Tinder and his popular
mental games?
Mental game of poker books?
Yeah.
Okay.
So I haven't read those books,
so I can't make the comparison,
but I can answer the first part of the question.
Um,
okay.
So there's something in poker called tilt.
Tilt is when our emotions,
um,
get lit up.
That shuts our frontal cortex prefrontal cortex down.
And,
uh,
we start making really bad decisions.
Um,
so I,
I say about poker has this really interesting quality of,
uh,
you're exchanging chips.
Oh,
you know,
every single hand.
And so it's letting you see that there's a risk in every single decision.
So that's the good thing.
The bad thing is it's allowing you to get caught in the path.
Right?
So,
um,
if you think about it,
I mean obviously what we'd really like is to think of ourselves as like the burr
a Berkshire Hathaway stock,
right?
We want,
we want a general upward trend to our happiness stock over our lifetime.
Um,
and if you look at birth or hack Berkshire Hathaway from the moment of its
inception,
it has that general leopard twin and it looks like a pretty nice little ride.
But if you look at it on a given day,
it might have a sharp downturn.
And in poker,
because you've got this exchange happening all the time,
you end up doing what's called ticker watching and you can really see those down
swings and you can really feel those upswings.
And so you start getting yanked around in this kind of like path dependent.
Um,
uh,
you know,
you're very path dependent in terms of where your emotions are.
So,
and this is generally a problem in life,
right?
So as an example,
like let's say that you're on the side of the road and you have a flat tire and
it's raining and it's really cold and you don't have a jack.
And you called Aaa and you know,
they take forever.
Um,
and so you're just cursing your life,
right?
Like you're just thinking like,
I have the unhappiest life.
I can't even imagine it.
Why do these things always happen to me?
Oh,
do you think it matters if you got a promotion three days before?
Are you like,
no,
hold on a second.
Let me actually take the average of my happiness over the last three days.
No.
Yeah.
It's like literally what happened three days ago doesn't matter.
You're only,
you're really deep down in that moment.
So this actually gives us a clue to how we deal with this and it's part of how
poker players deal with it.
So if I were to say to you,
okay,
let's say that you had that flat terror a year ago,
do you think that that would have affected your happiness one bit over the
course of the last year?
That one incident?
I actually,
to tell you the truth,
I actually think it would,
I think it would,
uptick.
I think it would cause enough ticking your happiness because it's a really good
cocktail party story.
Um,
uh,
interesting articles that I've seen a lot of kind of current events and thinking
about it in terms of um,
resulting or the hindsight bias or self serving bias or motivated reasoning or
whatever it might be,
to really kind of look at how,
what are things that are happening out in the world that can help us to try to
figure out how to be better decision makers.
So,
um,
like this week for example,
I talked a little bit about the NFL draft and decision making around the NFL
draft.
Um,
I also talked about a really interesting study that was done on a inducing
intellectual humility melody in,
uh,
high school students and how that actually increases their ability to learn,
um,
to really get that into that sort of mode of,
I'm not sure.
Um,
so that was in there I talked about as something from near I all on the peak end
rule and how you can hack that in order to make your memory's better and your
experiences better or at least your memory of your experiences better.
Um,
uh,
so that,
you know,
and then I'll also talk about things in that,
I not in this particular one,
but like last week I think I talked about current events,
things that are happening in politics,
um,
and that kind of thing.
So hopefully people will subscribe to the newsletter.
You can actually find archives of the newsletter on Annie duke.com so you don't
have to buy it until you actually test the product.
So you can,
you can go see what your podcast,
you do a great job doing that.
Well,
I appreciate that.
Um,
so I'm not,
so I've had that suggestion.
I,
I'm thinking about it right now because of the launch of the book.
I'm doing a lot of podcasts.
Um,
and so I'm kind of enjoying that at the moment.
I've done some really,
really fun ones.
Um,
and one,
and actually it's exposed me to a bunch of podcasts that I didn't know about.
So that's been actually Super Fun,
is that I'm,
I'm getting to find out about some podcasts that I wasn't personally aware of.
I love podcasts because I think,
I mean some of them are obviously like,
you know,
your 15 minute deals,
but,
but the ones that are more like this,
um,
where you get to go,
you get to do a deep dive.
And then what I find that's so amazing about them is that I rarely come from
away from a podcast where I haven't learned something.
I mean,
I'm always not just one thing either,
like so much where you get to sit and talk to somebody who's obviously really
smart and really engaged and see what their perspective on your product is,
is so cool.
And it's just like such gratitude for how it,
it changed.
Like you,
you come in and you're like,
well this is my,
this is my work product.
And then you come away going,
oh my gosh,
what a cool,
like I didn't think of that and I was so challenged in that makes me think about
it in a different way.
And Oh,
this relates to this in a way that I hadn't thought before.
So I'm just enjoying that process right now.
And then we'll,
we'll see.
I don't
know.
We'll see what the future holds in terms of anything else.
Excellent.
Well,
if you haven't already,
grab her book.
It's called thinking in bets,
making smarter decisions when you don't have all the facts.
If we can give her a please shoot Reynolds
[inaudible].